Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P. This is a
this is a tough voicemail. I'm going to play for
you guys today. This voicemail is a combination
of someone who doesn't know what's going on
politically, but also doesn't understand my show.
They claim to understand my show. But you're going
to notice in this segment they say you're doing
white supremacy on your show, David. You're doing
white supremacy. You're doing xenophobia. You did
a segment about how Haitians have aids, seemingly
misunderstanding that. My segment was about
Donald Trump's claim that Haitian immigrants
are just bringing AIDS over. That wasn't me
saying it. I reported on it, and you'll notice
that this is someone who has this is this is
endemic in the United States. Many opinions
based on things they misunderstood or misheard.
Speaker 5: So this is in regards to debate
about vaccines, first foremost. Like,
who are you? I mean, I see a young guy going with,
thank you. Trying to make money on the basis of
being white. You just seem to concentrate on being
Speaker 1: white or being liked. I'm Hispanic. I
don't even know what he's talking about.
But again, you don't have to watch me.
This is people don't seem to understand. Just
because a show exists doesn't mean you have
to send in every opinion you have about it
Speaker 5: or even watch it because opinion
without adding any critical thought. I can
to figure out if it's all I see is all of
these attempts to get the relevancy. Forty three
have you. Twenty four K views, racist crap like
Haitian migrants have aid is obviously a racist.
Speaker 1: Did you guys hear that? He says that my
clip about Haitian Haitian migrants having aids
was me doing a racist segment. Trump said it.
Trump said it. I'm reporting on it.
By the way, in terms of average views,
our average video now gets 75000 often, you
know, 200000 300000. The channel's actually blown
up. But does it matter? Does this person care?
Speaker 5: I mean, it's just it's just so funny
because people like you actually contribute
absolutely nothing to our generation.
This guy's contributing, although
I'm, you know, I don't think he'll
do too well in the long term. I love that.
Speaker 1: That's the best. I love it when people
who have no idea what I'm doing say, there's
no way this could possibly last and is like,
Well, we've been doing it for six years and last
month we were the biggest that we had ever been.
This is the circling the drain meme. Two of
my favorite memes, you're circling the drain.
Every one of your platforms is dying. Fact check,
we're bigger than ever. The other one that I love.
Well, actually, I wouldn't even I'm
not even going to going to do the
unsubscribe trolls people who say I'm now
unsubscribing because of something you said
and they were often never subscribed
to begin with or they're not really
unsubscribing. OK, that's a departure.
Speaker 5: You're not a, you know, anyone
who really brings any worth to society except
for trying to get people excited and trying to
misinform the general public. So I guess
that's really basically the argument is,
I mean, what's the point of having a discussion
with someone who is so irrelevant and untalented?
Speaker 1: What I love about that is no one's
forcing him to have a discussion with me. He
didn't even have to call in
Speaker 5: from birth,
but from beginning to constantly just
try and force some objective opinion.
Speaker 1: What is the
objective opinion? Even mean?
Isn't opinion by by its very nature subjective
Speaker 5: that doesn't even come from your own?
You know, this is a bunch of, yeah,
racist KKK stuff on your page.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there it is. So I'm doing my
channels, a KKK channel. So that is just a really
stunning combination of someone who doesn't even.
Understand my views is angry that the show exists,
claims it's ending soon. Doesn't want to engage
with it, but it's choosing to engage with it
on the basis of things that
they misunderstood or misread.
You really can't fix this stuff. You. I don't
know how we deal with that, folks. I really don't.
We will talk on today's bonus show.
High schoolers are training to drive 18
wheelers because of a shortage of truck drivers
high schoolers. We will also talk about Dr. Fauci
saying, Hey, you know what, if your family is
vaccinated, you can get together for Christmas
after being misquoted. He's now
actually saying it. That's OK to do.
And lastly, there is a wild situation developing
with Chicago police officers between the mayor and
the union over the vaccine mandate. We are going
to talk about what is happening. It's getting
very, very ugly with Chicago police. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at
join Packman dot com to get instant access.
Unidentified: And I will see you then.